I was a real-estate developer for about
20 years which is a highly
entrepreneurial business did about 2,500
projects all over the world and ended up
with one of the most complex tax returns
I'm told in the United States because of
all these separate legal entities so
that was a relatively entrepreneurial
business but I got out of real estate
and had to figure out what am I gonna do
with my next life and I started starting
businesses and backing entrepreneurs and
feeling like gosh this is a whole lot
like real estate development to back
entrepreneurs so when you think about
topics to talk to entrepreneurs about
culture is one of the last ones you
typically think about because you're in
the business of getting something
started it's chaotic and the last thing
you're thinking about is culture
building I mean it's just the most
irrelevant topic you could possibly have
and I'm gonna try to convince you that
it's not as irrelevant as you think I
was teaching a similar kind of course a
few years back and I asked I called on
cold-called on one of the entrepreneurs
in the audience about nasty Moe about
culture and he said we don't have any
culture in our business I said so we
don't we don't need no stinkin culture
right well you have a culture when
you've decided you don't have a culture
you've got one there is no way - it's
like air you've got a culture and so the
question is do you want to influence it
or not do you really want to have a hand
in shaping it or not you are going to
have it either inadvertently or with
some planning and some forethought so
that's what we're going to kind of talk
about today I've got kind of my notes
hmm
so in investing in a lot of businesses
by the way I've bought about 75
companies and started a bunch of I am on
my third startup airline to show you how
stupid I really am and I'm actually
working with curt hawkins up here on
developing a plane I mean it was going
from bad to worse here Kirk has a really
interesting idea if anybody talked about
a really cool entrepreneurial idea he's
got it so we're just starting our newest
one we've just announced it in Brazil so
we're starting a new Brazilian airline
I'm the vice chairman at JetBlue Airways
if any of you if anybody in here flown
JetBlue oh good good well I'm should
give you free tickets or something for
showing up here so this idea about why
do early-stage businesses fail you know
I mean I think the classical answer is
their context you know all of them
experienced these three things
uncertainty scarcity and dynamism
they're all operating in that kind of an
environment so they're all dealing with
these sorts of things and there's
nothing that feels like it has anything
to do with culture there well there's a
guy by the name of eat Chuck a disease
who wrote a book a number of years ago
is a professor at UCLA called corporate
life cycles we was sort of looking at
what what happens to companies as they
progress as they grow and so a lot of
you are starting way down here in your
entrepreneurial efforts you know where
you're thinking about an idea starting
to talk to investors putting together a
business plan all the way through the
time that you're starting to develop a
project or product new beta testing all
the way through and and finally
entrepreneurs kind of get businesses
often through prime where they are
really have systems up and running in
the businesses is approaching stability
so what white why do they fail what you
want to do is obviously is extend the
period of prime or stability for a
business and never get to those later
stages
a business and we could spend a lot of
time and kind of identify what
businesses are in various stages that we
know about it's kind of an interesting
and fun thing to do but here are the
most common causes of failure in the
entrepreneurial stages I think everybody
would have named liquidity you know the
seven great lessons of Highly Effective
entrepreneurs basically are don't run
out of cash you know that's the main
thing they say illiquidity not having
enough capital to get things done is the
number one cause the second one is that
they don't make the good hire fire
decisions they don't hire carefully
enough and they don't fire quickly
enough and they don't get the right team
together the third one is culture then
the fourth one that you realize is
dealing with the founder I know that's
not anything that all of you budding
entrepreneurs want to hear but often
times the founder is a problem and
getting to the next stage something
almost always needs to be done and then
the final one is adjusting the offering
something like 97% of all successful
entrepreneurial ventures have a
different product or service in the end
than the one that they had in their
early stage business plan I mean it's
extraordinary how much morphing needs to
go on to get to a business this is
really at its prime so these are kind of
a reasonable we're gonna talk to today
about is this middle one this culture
one that we kind of think of as you know
the least hard edge the fuzziest so wiki
is culture you heard somebody talk this
morning about wikia what is Wikia
sculture can you tell from we sat there
for an hour with the guy who's running
it yeah
yeah they love what they do there's a
lot of passion around the product what
other things do you pick up yeah high
tolerance for failure experimentation
kind of sloppiness chaos they celebrate
chaotic activity you know yeah yeah very
much openness transparency you know
around what they do other
characteristics yeah high degree of
collaboration both internally and an
expectation of the market but that is
the nature of human beings that they
enjoy collaboration we could go on and
on but here are the ones that I wrote
down here Zwicky as' culture now how
many of you in here are going to be
applying to Gil now why not now it could
be just because you have your own
ventures going but let's say you're a
second you're a second year MBA student
you're looking for a job would this
appeal to you or not we could talk about
this for a while or why not but I want
to get through these slides so we'll
just have you think about that but
there's often a question of fit you know
you've read this book blink about sort
of how we thin slice and we go in very
quickly we're able to pick up whether or
not we fit whether or not we like the
culture we like the spirit of the
enterprise that's going on it and people
tend to congregate around these values
that make up a culture so he I think is
probably the embodiment of that culture
there so I'd like you to take a few
minutes and think about what is the
culture of your business and let's take
two or three minutes and just pair up
and talk with you know however you can
and just describe in a few words what is
the culture of your enterprise just take
a take a practice run of this
how many of you think you could in six
words describe your partner's culture
how many of you think you could do your
own culture in six words well let me
give you that as an assignment to think
about that there's an entry phone story
the Ernest Hemingway was asked to write
the shortest short story a six word
short story and that has spawned this
whole idea that you see around of
writing a six-word memoir so to write
your own memoir in six words it's a also
a very valuable thing to write your
culture down in to capture your culture
in six words why in six word there's by
the way there's nothing magical about
six words but why that general notion
any reason for that it's about the
maximum of what people can remember none
of you could remember there wasn't
anybody that said I know all six of the
things or I know you know whatever they
said it really is kind of at the limit
of what we can remember so there's kind
of a a good of a good energy that gets
around eliminating things like that so
here's here's some six word memoirs and
I would I would bet you that any of you
could take almost any of these memoirs
and write a great story I mean this
captures a whole lot of the pathos of
the activities of a person's life you
know there's another group just to give
you a feeling
and who would have thought you could
capture so much a life I like that MVM
be a CPA JT ROA MVP IPO I mean I know
that guy yeah or failed Sat lost
scholarship I know that guy
I actually know that last woman it's not
my wife but you kind of get the idea
that there is something powerful about a
culture that gets captured in a few
images a few words because gonna be
remembered and bought into and you saw
that sitting in on that top we kind of
captured as a group what the culture was
at Wikia and I bet you that that's
something that Gil would relatively be
relatively comfortable with so your
culture in six words think about that so
I want to give you a couple of things
here that may be tools for you this is
kind of a map for building a great
culture it may seem irrelevant to you at
this stage but if you want to extend the
stages of before your enterprise sort of
starts to decline if you want to extend
it you really want to think about
culture building not doing it will cause
you to fail in ways that you'll wonder
what happened when the wheels come off
so here's a map some of you who've had
me in class know that this is my
favorite map for running and building a
business this comes from Marvin Bower
anybody know Marvin Bower is yeah he was
the founder of McKinsey he was also a
lawyer with Jones Day Revis and poem one
of the two or three largest law firms in
the world
so he's a multi-talented guy and
basically his map was that you've got to
get alignment you've got to have perfect
alignment between these five characters
and you put different words on back his
top where he called the philosophy
you've got to have a philosophy that
really drives you which never changes
and that's why and it's made up of a
couple of key values so that's why it's
small up at the top of the triangle and
that will drive an objective or a cup
of objectives which then will generate
your strategy your tactics will have
many more efforts and finally metrics or
controls can change all the time but
it's getting alignment in all of those
things that is the map for creating a
great culture so let's talk a little bit
about each of these as we kind of go
down first thing is this idea of values
values being observable you know it's
sometimes when you ask entrepreneurs
what their values are they say things
like integrity honesty forthrightness
those are virtues so I want to make a
distinction between virtues and values
values are where you spend your time
your money and your mind share so one of
the great value statements that a
company has is its budget a budget is a
value statement because that says how
much are we going to spend on R&D how
much are we gonna spend on salaries how
are we gonna do so these are values so
what really drives your your values in
your enterprise and think that one
through pretty careful here where you
find some real value conflicts if you
don't think about I lived in a business
for a long time where we were a grow
fast business we were all about what we
could have cared less about profits we
were all about the balance sheet we were
building us big a balance sheet as we
could to heck with the profits it just
didn't matter so we were building and
building and building and building and
growing well there came a time when it
was a problem not to have profits we
could not turn the ship because our
values our systems our compensation
everything that we did was around
starting new projects all of the energy
all the personnel everybody was about
starting new projects you see a lot of
conflict in enterprises between this you
know is that customers our employees our
customers our shareholders or
shareholders are employed when there's
tension who do you really spend time
with I saw the best example the guy that
I worked with when I first went to work
out of business school is a fella by the
name of Trammell
who's a big real-estate developer he
owned the Dallas merchandise smart do
any of you know on Stemmons freeway
there it's about a seven million square
foot wholesale Merchandise Mart so
buyers come in there and examine goods
and there was a big buyer that came
through the turnstile there and a woman
was checking IDs that had worked for
travel for many many years and this guy
was he didn't have his ID with him and
so he became really abusive with this
older woman and just said Do You Know
Who I am and just started really kind of
cursing at her and everything
tremble cut a view of it out of the
corner of his eye and he walked over
there and took the fella by his arm said
I'm sorry we do not treat employees the
Dallas Market Center this way you'll
have to leave and he walked this
important buyer to the front door and
out how long do you think it was before
that story got around to all of the
employees in that enterprise it was
within the hour that Trammell had walked
over and protected an input now I'm not
saying that's the right value
necessarily it's just he made very clear
that his job was going to be to take
care of his employees that his employees
would then take care of customers and
that therefore the business would work
well and the shareholders would be taken
care of that was his prayer but a lot of
times you get people where it's an
unclear what the order of priority is
there well you can see tenure and merit
a lot of times you see enterprises that
who's here the longest gets the gets the
promotion or inside versus outside hires
current views power versus common does
the best idea win or does the most
powerful person's idea win these are all
values things this is all part of your
culture and the wheels come off in
enterprises if you don't have alignment
with these value if you aren't clear
about these values and get them captured
in a few words so the second thing that
is objectives you know and take a second
here on on objectives what my favorite
objective of all time is Pepsi's you
know this was from 20 years back Pepsi
subjective corporate objective was beat
Coke to two syllables not even just two
words do one syllable worth beat coke
that inspired Pepsi
for 20 years and I actually was teaching
this to a group of YPO executives and
the guy said that he went over to his
brother-in-law's house who was a
warehouseman for Pepsi to a barbecue and
somebody had brought coca-cola products
and he wouldn't allow he wouldn't serve
them he went down to the local grocery
store bought Pepsi products and replaced
them so people were using the Pepsi
products there that's how powerful this
was it got all the way through the
organization that we're about being well
in 2006 guess what Pepsi beat coke and
they did it through a bunch of
strategies and a bunch of tactics and
controls and measurements and
celebration but they made their
objective so here's the new Pepsi goal
it's a little more complex a little more
complicated a few more words but it's
also a pretty clear one it is to be the
model to the world of how you operate it
in a global environment this is this new
woman CEO and that's how she's
articulated what Pepsi's about well you
all know the JFK when land a man on the
moon bringing back safely within the
decade was a clear moonshot kind of a
goal that inspires people and then
finally my my favorite one of all time
is Winston Churchill you know in 1940
this is three days after the Germans
crossed the Meuse river Winston
Churchill was on his way here with
Neville Chamberlain and Clement Attlee
to visit Parliament and this is where he
delivered that famous blood toil tears
and sweat speech and there was a 43 word
paragraph in a very short speech by the
way nobody really applauded Richard they
gave a huge applause to Neville
Chamberlain and Churchill gave this and
in 43 words five of them are the word
victory is it at all unclear what the
objective of Churchill was and what was
Churchill's sign during World War two
exactly I mean he made it absolutely
clear what he was about what the
objective was nobody could forget it
was the embodiment of that objective and
so having a clear objective is the next
thing and that's gotta align with your
values so it's just that a lot your
values drive what it is you're trying to
achieve this is kind of the what is
winning in question this is one of the
most powerful questions as an
entrepreneur you can ask us envision
winning when I was running companies
actively I used to I used to write the
article about our company as if I were
looking back five years say
such-and-such was successful because
they did the following things and here's
what success was they achieved a hundred
million in sales in a faster time and
just describe it envision it write it
out so then the strategy is the next
thing that you do is you develop and
this is kind of where the overlap comes
between top management and middle
management middle management has to
understand and participate in the
development of strategy they have to own
the strategy and then they have to
execute it and I think the top
management is responsible for thinking
through values objectives and
participating in the development of
strategy so you kind of answer these
questions as you as you go down through
to get alignment so if you get perfect
alignment on these things you have this
thing that is called trust which is
really the lubricant of getting
enterprises so they can sustain
themselves so they can last so I want to
spend some time on what seems like a
really soft fuzzy notion this idea of
trust as a as a culture carrier but just
there's a Harris Poll down in 2005 and
sort of how many people really trust
these various enterprises my guess is
it's quite a bit higher in
entrepreneurial enterprises but I'd be
surprised if it's 50 percent or more
there's very little that people really
trust and it really bought into so what
is the nature of trust I think one of
the the best way just back to our
training one of the best ways to think
about that is to think about this
question who do you trust so
who do you trust I mean you can see back
here that certainly not the political
parties or big companies or media the
government or used-car salesman or so
who do you trust yeah family why why do
you trust family yeah they're looking
out for you
they're not gonna kind of screw you over
take advantage of you or do something
that's not in your interest I can do
something behind your back and which
family member you trust most you dog
they're clearly the most predictable you
can trust him to make a mess you can
trust him to do a bunch of a yeah
usually when I talked to you about this
it's mom you know yeah I mean your mom
is just there forever for you you know
you completely trust your mom so the
next question is it and if this is
really the the idea is that the that
their character is high character
they're looking out after you competence
is the next thing we look at it I don't
know if I yeah I put this side here when
I often ask people would you trust your
mom to fly you to New York in a 747
you really trust your mom you don't
really trust your mom for everything do
you and that kind of gets back to this
idea I mean character is not enough
you've got to have confidence you gotta
have ability to deliver and that's
really not even enough you really have
to have a power or an authority or means
to deliver in the way I
I generally illustrate this is by saying
that one of my partners is an attorney
he's a very capable attorney and I've
told him several times you know I'd
really prefer not to pay taxes this year
really be nice and be a good thing if
you just did this you're a capable guy
you've got high character you're very
competent just you know now deliver on
this thing well that would be a foolish
trust because he doesn't have the
authority he doesn't have the power to
make this happen so really you have to
have all three of these things to be
trustworthy or to trust in another and
to have a culture of trust all three of
these things have to be present so you
have to have high character people with
domain expertise and competence and they
have to be in power you have to have
alignment of power ability to deliver
otherwise you have low trust lower trust
than you need to build a high quality
enterprise and ultimately the wheels
will come up before you get all the way
up to stability so I just want to make
the point that I think if you'll think
about trust this way you'll see that
it's a really a pretty hard edged sticky
kind of a notion and it is vital it is
more than any other thing I can think of
vital in a crisis by that I mean I've
been with a bunch of business I've taken
a couple of businesses through Chapter
11 and back out the other side I've
taken several through workouts or an
really tough turn around swear it's not
just a turn around where you're selling
off assets and and paying off as many
creditors you can where you really want
to have a viable athlete when you're
done with the whole thing Trust is the
medium of exchange it's the only way
suppliers have to trust you employees
have to trust you your investors have to
trust you the marketplace your customers
I mean your trust is really how you get
through these to everything so when you
say entrepreneurial activity is a high
risk effort and they fail 9 out of 10
fail 75% don't make it to an up round
you know or get bought by history
teacher but so it's a high risk
interpret well what gets you through
that highest risk part is often having a
culture of trust you know having put
together the right team that trust one
another and can see themselves through
the tough times so here the three thing
that just a quick comment here is we
will forgive people who don't deliver if
they're unempowered we don't forgive
people who violate because a violator
trusts because of a character flaw who
aren't looking out for our interests who
lied to us who betray us so when you
think about these three components think
about if you're gonna violate one of
them make sure it's one that where you
just didn't have the authority to
deliver you'll get forgiveness and can
survive it so I think I'm trustworthy
worthiness as part of your brand and we
won't take the time here I mean another
another interesting exercise for people
who are starting running companies is to
think about your brand you're all
creating something or developing
something or selling something what what
is your brand in other words what are
you promising to the market what can the
market count on you what can your
employees count on you to be if you take
these automobile brands here do you have
an idea when you look at those brands do
they say something to you that's unique
or different generally do I think for
most of us these are brands that means
something and they have tag lines that
try to capture they're try they try to
tell they want you to believe certain
things about the brands and I think for
the most part we kind of trust these
brands to be these things so to continue
on here on trust as this this medium of
exchange for building a culture I want I
want to introduce you to three kinds of
trust talk about a fewer thing and then
I want I want to wrap up with an
exercise here where you you're gonna try
to evaluate your own enterprise whether
it's a high medium or low trust
enterprise by answering ten questions so
that's where we're headed with this but
now just a few more minutes on
what is trust first of all there's this
reciprocal trust where your your
trusting each other this is the highest
format it's like a relay race you know
where runners in a relay race pass the
baton to each other and the time of the
relay team is always faster than the
fast a high school relay team a high
school 440 relay team will run the 440
faster than the Olympic gold-medalist
why because they are working together
they're trusting each other they're
passing the baton they're they've got
their gun and they're young and they're
not running as far but that's kind of a
reciprocal turn you find that in
partnerships and families and and in
entrepreneurial enterprises this is
really the best kind of trust that when
you're digging in start-up stages having
a reciprocal trust is the best form you
then have representative trust this is
the kind of trust you've got with your
doctor or with your accountant or your
lawyers or whatever where really it's
uneven you know there were just
representing you all they're trusting
you to do is give them information
accurate information that's the only
thing you have to do and then they
you're trusting them to make the
diagnosis to do the operation to file
your tax returns to develop documents so
that's representative trusted we see a
lot of that in business and then the
final is counterfeit trust where you're
dealing with coincident interests this
is the most dangerous kind of trust and
it's the kind of trust that you find
most often in business where really
you're just saying you know it's in your
interest in my interest therefore we can
trust we can trust each other to both be
selfish you know we're like Mafia dons
we're making a deal you know and we know
that we won't be able to deal we won't
be able to trust each other beyond
acting in our self-interest but that's
the only kind of trust that we can have
so these are the kind of the three kinds
of trust that you run into commercially
so you have high medium and low trust
organizations that really relate to this
kind of these motivators so now I won't
spend much time on this but if you
really think about it these are the only
five things that motivate people in your
organization or motivate you I've
thought about this for 40 years now and
tried to find something that doesn't fit
in one of these categories I think we
all are motivated you know so if
somebody puts a gun to
your head says Susan you're motivated to
do it that's called force you know or
maybe fear so business is they all say
business runs by fear and greed most
businesses are operated out of fear and
great
most families operate out of a sense of
duty and love and if you array various
organizations across this you can kind
of see well prisons how long do you
think people behave in prisons if they
don't if the if the actual motivator
isn't right there it doesn't last very
long and get in families you can remove
all external motivators and the culture
will maintain there's just such a high
trust there's high reciprocal trust that
the culture is so powerful that you
don't have to have extrinsic motivators
so I think the idea in an
entrepreneurial organization is to try
to move yourself up this motivational
scale so that people are doing things
more for the reasons they do in
foundations the military churches
families high-level partnerships
etc so let's look at a couple of much
studied cultures here these are bigger
companies and we don't study a lot of
the small ones but these are three of
the most famous companies that have been
studying HP way we've all read about you
know what makes and and notice on all
these there'll be three things three
values that drive so it's a respect for
others sense of community hard work
that's the HP way the document look at
IBM respect others best customer service
tasks are done in a superior way Walmart
respect the individual service to
customers strive for excellence what do
you see in common they're all the same
they're all exactly the same
doesn't it say something to me about
maybe they've thought about this worker
these are some of the most successful
companies in the world they've thought
about it worked at it had infinite
meetings about this stuff and they've
all come down to the same values that
drive food as they are so oops I think I
went one too far No so basically the
common values that these companies have
are
are these these three so why don't you
just go home back to your little
businesses the estranged is copy what
the pros have spent millions of dollars
in decades developing would that be the
simplest thing to do
white spend the time to develop your own
set of values objectives culture just
Xerox this you know it's the easiest
thing I think the issue is the same
issue that you have with strategy and
execution they always say that every
strategy that's out there in the world
can be read about I mean it becomes part
of the public domain immediately so
everybody knows everybody's strategy the
priceless thing the thing that cannot be
replicated though is the quality of
execution it all comes down to execution
so if you take we'll just take the
Walmart example here quickly to give you
a feel for how Sam Walton did this so
Sam came up with his associates with ten
rules these aren't worth copying down
there it's just more look olestra did
we're you see you know he figured out
these are the ten rules if you want to
be part of the Walmart culture and have
these values he's now operationalizing
these which are very homey homely kind
of well we learned these at our mother's
knee we don't need the Sam Walton to
tell us these then he reinforces the
culture with a sundown rule sundown rule
says by the end of the day every
question gets answered so from a
customer and associate we answer every
question the Walmart cheer we all get
when we get together we do w w ay ay l L
squiggly squiggly and and adult adults
get together and do the Walmart chair
why in the world well that is
reinforcing these values of community
and people matter the ten-foot rule
basically if you come within 10 feet of
a customer you go up and ask naive so
anytime you make eye contact with them
and you go up and ask how you can help
everyday low prices that means you fly a
flight coach
you stay in a motel room with another
Walmart executive you save money that
you can pass on to customers
that's what everyday low price is right
and the fifth thing he does is the
Saturday morning get-together swear bono
comes and does rock concerts and CEOs
come and the vice president shows up I
mean these are huge corporate
celebrations of being part of Walmart so
this reinforcing the culture is way more
important than the three values it's the
execution around the builds the culture
it's fun stuff what makes it fun to be
there so the map you know is this simple
map just getting alignment between these
things alignment builds high trust high
trust is a currency that will save your
bacon as an entrepreneur it will help
you in so many ways when you cannot see
through the fog you don't know wow
you're gonna meet the next payroll you
don't know how you're gonna service the
debt you don't know how you're gonna get
that shipment out you don't know how
you're gonna get rid of the inventory
that you you got too much up high trust
if you've built these kinds of cultures
of high trust it'll see you through a
lot of down cycles so here's the ooo you
now to pick any organization that you're
in probably the one that's your you're
the business that you're founding or
working in that's a small business but
ask these 10 questions of yourself and
be honest you know you don't even I'm
not gonna collect these you're not gonna
show them to anybody you're just gonna
look at these 10 things and evaluate
this enterprise based on it and then
assess whether or not alo I'll tell you
at the end it's gonna be you're gonna be
assessing it 1 through 10 10 is always
true reliably true 1 or 0 is this is
never the case it's always violated and
somewhere in between is I can't count on
it it is sometimes true sometimes not
pick any number in between and then give
yourself a score so pick a business
school fat your own family church any
other organization and we're gonna rate
it along these 10 dimensions here so
here are the 10 questions
the first one is ten questions the first
one is the integrity of the leader so
this is where you ask yourself is the
person who's running this business or is
there personal like do they have
integrity in their personal life and
their needs I've known a lot of people
who that they may not cheat in the
business but you know they're doing
things that are dishonest in their
personal lives they're taking advantage
of people friends or family or whatever
there's no division in their in their
character between their private and
their personal life is so think about
you if you're if you're the leader of it
how would your employees are hoped to be
hired employees evaluate you on this
what they see you as having complete
integrity personal and private give
yourself a score is there mutual respect
among team players the various people
that are there our individuals more
important than policy bureaucracy how do
the interactions with the powerless go
on in your organization
in other words how do you treat the
people who who have no ability to make
your business go one way or the other I
always used to look when I went into an
enterprising of evaluating whether or
not did invest how do they treat the
receptionist how do they treat the
person who cleans up the office
afterwards if they treat the powerless
the people who really can in a certain
way you can you can anticipate that
they'll be fairly high trust if they
treat them as dirt ignore them or
whatever trust levels are generally
lower and then finally do they bash
people either inside or out the
organization talked about it was an
irritant airline story listening to
actually I've got several I pick the
most carefully selected one where they
talked about the passengers well we've
got all the cattle are on
you know it's time to feed the cows or
feed the cattle you know and you think
that doesn't replicate itself with all
the flight attendants and the folk you
know so how do you how do you respect
people inside the organization outside
the organization north south east and
west and if there's high degree of
respect for all and you'll notice that's
the one of the ones that IBM Walmart and
HP had is respecting individuals the
third one is you empower people to help
them to achieve their very best or are
you about keeping them from doing their
worst these these policy manuals these
paraphernalia or paranoia you know where
you're just watching up making sure
nobody takes advantage of you I've been
in organizations where it's all about
rules and making sure you don't do your
worst
versus the ones where they're just
celebrating liberating you to do your
best the fourth one is if you aligned
Authority and responsibility and
accountability so that if somebody is
responsible for some they've got the
authority to get it done and they have
accountability they get feedback on it a
lot of times you'll see this divided up
in low trust organizations you'll assign
one person to do it you'll measure it
someplace else
you'll give somebody else the authority
to do it those are almost always low
trust organization so you have those
lined up across the board the fifth one
is has to do with your mission statement
most organizations have gotten tired of
doing vision statements or mission
statements why because they feel like
they could have been written and
published you know you could grab them
out of a book the only thing that's a
value about valuable about them is the
process of creating it is getting people
together and saying well what are we
about what are what is our big dream
what would we like to achieve what are
what do we want and so it has to be
developed by the team and it really has
to be inspirational to people otherwise
people become cynical around it if it's
just one that you've created or that's
existed for a long time or you copy
out of the Walmart book there will be
cynicism and low trust that comes along
with it the sixth one has to do with
communications you know do you tell the
truth and telling the truth do you do it
soon you do it completely and you tell
the truth about bad news as well as good
news a lot of entrepreneurial
organizations especially I've been tend
to tell good news is that and it's a
little bit like the wiki a guy who's
talking about you know celebrate make
yourself bigger puff your chest out make
people believe you're more you have to
be very careful with that because people
are smart they figure it out and if you
and if they feel like you're blowing
smoke all the time the trust levels go
down
you may think you're pumping them up but
it gets less and less and you have to
pump the harder all the time so do you
communicate clearly frequently and
broadly does the organization require
sacrifice we love what we sacrifice for
that's what may really seem strange but
think about you're in the military Kurt
you have great memories there because
you you had big sacrifice I have great
memories about Harvard Business School
which is a miserable place this is on
tape Oh rats we got it we got to cut
that part out I wouldn't say that the
first let me just say it this way part
of the first year was not the happiest
thing but I sacrificed I stayed up all
night I worked on stuff I look back on
it and it's some of my best friend I had
a friend one time that said man what I
want to have is a little boy I just
cannot wait till I'm a father and I have
a little boy and he had a little boy and
he thought well this isn't so great this
is a mewling puking little this is not
the greatest thing after all
and then his wife got sick and she was
so ill she could not take care of this
little baby and so he found himself
getting up in the middle of the night
walking this child feeding it formula
changing its pants and by the end of the
week he was so in love and so cared so
much about that little baby because he'd
sacrificed for it I know that's a funny
example
they give to a bunch of it but you love
the companies that you found you love
the people in the trenches with you it
really meant you so don't be afraid of
sacrifice if you want a high trust
organization ask people to sacrifice for
it the trust levels will go up and the
leaders can't keep peace in that kind of
area say by placating the powerful you
know everybody has to sacrifice the most
powerful as well as the least powerful
adversary right this is the one so I've
taught this to YP owers and this is the
one where I've gotten pushback and I'd
say it's about 75% of them push back on
this one and I argue with them on it
because I think high trust organizations
share their budgets I think people know
them anyway they figure it out
you know people are really smart and so
my view is talk to them about the budget
let them know what's going on share with
them what they and people start to solve
problems they buy in they understand
what your values are and you start to
get real alignment in the organization
but I've had a lot of people push back
on that one so you may not buy that one
but that's my view conflict so forth
what's the level of conflict in the
organization is it allowed is it
celebrated your organizations that don't
have conflict include hospitals prisons
you know there's a lot of places where
there's no conflict and there's a kind
of a quiet that is an unreal quiet I
think you want organizations to
celebrate dispute to openly conflict
that you know have it be something that
you can really talk about it's a good
thing I used to have a partner that
after every presentation he would say I
want your criticism and if you said well
that was really terrific he said no no I
don't want to know that I want to know
what could I have done better and he
really sought it out and you saw him
make changes when you did that so I
think that's really what you want is you
want the kind of conflict and directness
and trust levels tend to rise if you
have that surprisingly
and then the final one is high trust
organizations have a level of humility
about them every organization is like a
cork on the sea do you think about every
once in a while people get feeling but
I've been parts of pretty big
organizations who have felt really
powerful I led the largest private real
estate company in the world and we were
feeling pretty powerful and pretty smart
and some days
pretty good-looking and and you start
getting that feeling and then you really
realize in our business it's all credit
driven it's all you're leveraged
interest rates can change on yeah I mean
occupancy rates can go down pretty
quickly and all of a sudden you're you
can be wiped out and that is true of
just about any business it would not
take much to wipe out most businesses
and we've seen it happen with some of
the bigger businesses in fact if you
look at the hundred businesses that were
around a hundred years ago I think there
are three that are left in the top 100 I
mean so huge enterprises have gone out
of business that seemed very powerful so
there needs to be a level of humility
and so I think that organizations that
talk about their vulnerabilities about
their weaknesses who share them develop
a really a reality check and a trust
level with each other that is really
likely to see them through tough times
those who sugarcoat everything I think
develop a cynicism again because this
idea that people are smart so net-net
developing a culture you have your best
shot at doing it in a sense if you think
about it when you're the only person
there you are the culture your first
hire can improve on that culture or
dilute that culture but that first hire
will change the culture and then it's
really a question almost of gravity you
know as you add bodies you know the
culture gets moved by the gravity of
what is the most common set of beliefs
and values which is one of the reasons
that's really important to talk about
them to have them out in the open an
entire base
values because people will not
compromise values
they'll compromise tactics they'll
compromise strategy
they'll compromise to a degree their
objectives but by the time you get to
values people are really those you're
deeply entrenched kinds of views that we
hold so higher for values and fire for
lack of coincidence of values so we've
got about seven or eight minutes here
that was a much longer in terms of
presentation that I wanted bill I was
just kind of take that through to get a
framework for you but let's talk now
about your thoughts or questions or
comments yeah
well you know I think if you go back to
this idea of in thinking about I I think
it starts out with knowing your own
values you know what do you really care
and I think I think you go back I think
if I could follow you around
for a week I could tell you what your
values are because of this notion of
time money and mine share now you may
say that there's something else and so
I'd have it there be a there'd be an
integrity again I'm not picking on you
saying that there's an integrity gap
I'm just saying with all of us with all
of us we say one thing I mean I have a I
have a really nice ideal set of values
but then you watch what I do and I
watched a little TV and I relax and then
I eat more chocolate than I really
should so chocolate is an important
value to me relaxation is an important
value to me I like fast cars so I spend
more money on fast cars than I should I
mean so these are really my value so I
have all these things that I I like to
say over here but somewhere in my value
system is this other thing you know one
of the ways that I learned this most
painfully was I asked my kids one time
to say what does dad say and what does
dad do
and so they listed all these things that
I say all the time you know work hard
you know don't sleep in you know brush
your teeth you know all the things that
parents say to children now what do you
see dad do thinking that it would be
well he really works hard and he brushes
his teeth and he's a good guy and then
so they listed not all these things and
I remember the last one on my
six-year-old child's list was you eat
slim-fast
and M&Ms
you hypocrite you know I mean she had
picked up from what I do
watching me that you know I wasn't
totally consistent you know and so I
think you really pay a whole lot of
attention figuring out first who you are
and then you start thinking about people
that share those guys and I don't think
values are necessarily around your own
personal characteristics in a business
as much as they are around business
values I think to me the most powerful
business values are growth growth is a
value you really care about growing
because growing means that you are able
to produce a product that the
marketplace sees as having greater value
to them than it costs them if you could
produce something that people say this
is worth more to me than it costs me
you're gonna grow I promise you that is
a recipe for growth so growth is one of
these business values so I like people
who really want to grow who get excited
by growing by taking products to the
marketplace by selling or profits to me
is a business value because the profits
to me says you know I don't get to set
the price on what it is I'm selling the
marketplace will set the price I don't
get to do that all I can do is manage my
costs and the difference between the
price I set and my costs is my profit so
what that says is I'm efficient if I can
really be efficient so I like hiring
people who care about making profits
because that says they've figured out
how to be efficient how to do more for
less they care about saving money doing
things in a quick efficient way so to me
profits and growth are business values
so they don't I mean they're not what
people would expect and then finally to
me the most powerful one of all is this
respect for other human beings I think
that will carry you so far in building a
business and and it I think it is seen
in how you treat every single person
with whom you have an interaction and I
can pick that up so quickly walking
around with people just watching how
they transact their lives and so to me
those are those are the really the three
powerful business
values but it'll be different for
various of you is you really think
through who you are how do you think
business work what what really motivates
you all day long as you run your
business
to me it's can we sell this thing really
well because it's providing a great need
and great value for our customers can we
produce it efficiently effectively and
low-cost and our people happy are we
treating people well so this is a great
place would we make a difference in
their life we weren't there would that
make a difference to our employees or
they just say well I'll go work
somewhere else I want to be in
businesses where the employees say man
we missed we this is a huge loss not to
have this company in place you know I
think that's maybe how you measure that
so that's I just shared with you what
mine are but figure out your own and
then hire people who get excited about
those same things I think yeah
they need to I mean you need to think
about all of them I know when I was
trying to shift from a balance sheet
company to an income statement company
or at least add an income statement to
the balance sheet I realized that we
were paying our young partners to build
more space and the only way they made
money was if they started a new project
and so we were saying hey we want you to
stop building all these new projects the
market won't absorb them you know stop
it and yet they were making eighteen
thousand dollars a year in salary taking
a draw against development profits the
only way they could survive was by
starting that new space so we didn't
change the compensation structure as we
were saying this is what we believe in
this is what the market is telling us
the the lack of of synchronizing those
two meant that it failed trust levels
went down it ended up in litigation it
was just impossible to manage it because
you didn't have this alignment so I
think it has to anytime you shift any of
those things you have to shift all of
you have to make sure that they stay in
alignment you got another minute yeah
yeah I mean it may be that you've got to
do it I would think I did things like
innovation being cutting edge testing
the market piloting thing I mean there's
a lot of things like that I've tended
not to be in those businesses I have
tended to back people or in those and
hope that they'll do that but you're
absolutely right so these aren't the
necessary values I'm kind of an old line
manufacturing service retailing you know
big industry guy and so I I do
entrepreneurial activity in those sorts
of things where those are appropriate
values but they're probably not in a lot
of the things that you guys are doing
that's a great comment thank you one
last question and then oh I thought it
went to 215 oh I'm sorry
they're right okay
well let's keep talking anybody who
wants to peel on out of here don't feel
like you're trapped you're Steve
yeah I think I think culture change
starts with yourself if you're the
leader of an organization I noticed when
I was running various divisions that if
I had a division where the guy who was
running it was overweight people tended
to be overweight or if he was a heavy
smoker people tended to smoke or if or
if he was a fighter pilot tended to hire
fighter pilots I mean so I think a lot
of it is figuring out who you are and
making yourself the best you you can be
then I think this very difficult thing
of letting people go who do not fit with
the values as the toughest thing to do
but I think you've got to make personnel
change it's very tough to get people to
adjust it right if they really are not
wired the way you're going they will
fight you the whole way so I think
you've got to be willing to do that the
other thing I think you have to do is
talk about it you just have to open it
up say let's talk about what we're
really about what do we want what are
our dreams what would winning be for us
these are all good questions yeah
then you change your culture for the
lowest common denominator and what that
does is alienate all of the people who
would buy into the greater culture and
that's why you have to you know
companies that build up Deadwood and
that's that's the most common thing that
happens is a company gets to a certain
size they just say well let's transfer
him over to accounts receivable or
whatever and you start building up
pockets of Deadwood in the company
rather do it and then you have to have a
policy manual that says okay this is how
we handle this and then pretty soon
people start to violate that and you
have to add more rules and then you have
these these it's you get like the IRS
code you know it's just that thick and
requires lawyers to interpret it and you
have conflict and whatever it's much
easier and the earlier you address it
the better and you really need a whole
lot fewer manuals Kurt
I do I mean
yeah I think I think having this map and
getting alignment between these is
really critical but where do you start
is not so important what I found when
I've gone into enterprises the easiest
place for me to start is right here with
the objective you know what are we
trying to achieve because people can you
can ask people what does winning look
like what would it feel like to win you
know and describe it put some flesh on
those bones you know how the athletes
when they talk about jumping over a high
bar something they envision themselves
running down the track leaping up over
the bar and clearing the bar and so if
that's what success is envision it now
describe it use words to describe it and
let's really get some flesh on those
bones now let's tie into what are the
values that would support that which is
something that is an underpinning that's
a higher level
there's probably fewer of them that
support that than anything else but I
think so to me as I go into
organizations and try to help them get
to a better place I always start with
the objective I think that is the
easiest place if you're intervening or
if you're a CEO and you you're worried
about your culture I think the best
place to start is with the objective and
but don't forget don't forget to get
back to values and don't forget to get
all the way down to a dashboard I mean
in the end great businesses have great
dashboards they really have figured out
you know what are the half a dozen to
ten dials that you've got to watch and
they're not and the ones that don't do a
good job are always looking at
historical dials what happened in the
past they're measuring the beans that
have been counted the really great ones
have some dials that look back there and
say well where have we been they have
some dials that are looking a sales
pipeline they have some diet
dials that are two or three steps
removed from what you think you need to
manage but you know that that's a key
driver in the business so you got to get
all the way through the whole thing
you've got to make sure you get the
dashboard built and you've got to tie
into values and it's that whole process
that allows you to build a great high
trust
culture Robert you actually destroy the
culture if you do if you if you don't
have integrity around them I mean it's
it's like a poison pill into the culture
but that is so true I don't know if I've
got this one slide anywhere here yeah
this is so when I evaluate a business
these are the four buckets that I look
at so I'm a now an investor in your
business and the very businesses you're
starting I'm I'm talking to people like
you all day long and I collect
information in these four buckets and so
I look at you know I probably start out
with what is the product or service that
you're involved in and I want to
understand that and then I want to
understand it in the context of the
marketplace how big is the market how
fast is it growing who else is in the
market and what are they doing what
unfair advantages do I have in that so I
look hard at that and then I want to
structure a deal at a relationship a
financial arrangement with you that goes
beyond that it's maybe a control
arrangement it may be a help advice
mentoring but I want to structure
something around that that meets your
needs and meets my needs and it's
consistent with those other two and then
the last thing I'm really looking at is
sort of evaluating the quality the
character the values of the leader again
this leader does this leader embody
values that are likely to build a great
culture and that may include things like
is this somebody who can see over the
horizon and this somebody who is a
celebrator of others success there's a
whole bunch of factors that go into a
successful leader if they fail on that
one so what I always do is I
you know in the end I can have I can
have a b-plus in those but I've got to
have an a I have I have yet to do a
successful deal where I've had a B in
the leadership and I've done a bunch of
deals for that it hasn't made a whole
lot of sense otherwise I wouldn't have
done airline deals because that there's
nothing about that industry that makes
any sense
I mean it's regulated high fuel prices
labor unions you got slotting you got I
mean it's everything is wrong with the
industry and you have crazies in the
business you have people that love to
pushed in and that's what they're about
I mean it's the dumbest industry it was
Warren Buffett that said you know the
best thing would have happened was if
Wilbur had shot Orville that's the best
thing for the airline business so and
yet and yet I've been able to back
people with high values integrity great
leadership adaptability seeing over the
horizon and so it's worked out so that
to me is the key bucket and you're right
it's very tough to build a culture so if
you don't have integrity if you treat
people poorly if you're disorganized if
you if you have all these
characteristics that are dysfunctional
you're gonna have a tough time building
a culture that will get past a certain
point now you may be able to bring
people in who can fill in for you but
ultimately most of those have the wheels
fall off at something with a few notable
exceptions yeah
to me they might be a great visionary it
is there's a couple of comments they'd
make the quick answers no I feel like if
you get it right two-thirds of the time
you'll be in the Hall of Fame I mean
it's really a tough thing to do you can
be fooled as experienced as you can get
but I I don't I've learned not to hire
myself you know which is the most
tempting thing when you first start out
in this you hire yourself because you
know yourself and you kind of like
yourself you know why wouldn't I want me
you know and that's almost always wrong
and then you don't hire resumes either I
used to hire resumes and I and so I was
hiring people that just have these
stellar resume I do hire for people
who've been successful who have had a
pattern of success I find people who've
been six and it may be that they were
the the star running back on the
football team I mean it doesn't matter
you know it may not be related but I
found that people who win tend to like
to continue to win they just have this
intense desire to get it done so and to
me hard work the ability to work hard
and to stay focused to be intelligent
they have high integrity and so I ask a
series of questions I ask a lot of
open-ended questions I don't like these
case if any we've done interviewed for
consulting firms you know they'll give
you up a little problem and say how
would you solve that would you unplug
the refrigerator whatever I think those
are just almost beyond silly for what
I'm looking for in any event so no there
I don't know a formula but I've gotten
better I still follow it up pretty
regularly but I'm better at it today
than I was yeah
well I'll tell you the one that I know
the best and that is the travel croco
yeah I mean they're clearly ones that
had violations of law but they had
violations of culture before they had
violations of regulations I mean it was
very clear that the Enron culture was a
sick culture way before they ran into
trouble but I the one that I know the
best is the Trammell Crowe company which
is the largest private real estate
company in the world and we were the
envy of every other real estate company
and because we're a balance sheet grow
fast company all of our partners were
multimillionaires and they started to
believe the press they started to feel
like you know we're rich guys and we're
pretty good-looking and we can just kind
of do whatever we want we're bulletproof
and we don't have to pay it so what when
I started looking at it I realized that
we were losing twenty-two million
dollars a year in current operations
we're making it up by developing new
space and we're kind of covering it up
with borrowings and if you just looked
at cash we were creating this big
balance sheet it was just it was Barry I
mean the 22 million we were losing and
curt operations was buried by hundreds
of millions made in the equities on our
properties so but it was very tough to
get that organization to say wait a darn
minute everything that we do all day
long every day is losing money it's only
if we can build into this rapid
environment that we survive we could not
stop that I mean it was just so that to
me that's one of the that's the tragedy
I know most personally but I I think the
there are the ones that have run into
regulatory problems that are tragedies
but I mean look at General Motors I mean
read Alfred P Sloan 'he's my years with
General Motors if you want to read a
brilliant business book buy a fabulous
engineer he built
General Motors as an engineer as a
technician he went in and took that
thing apart and put it back together
figured out market segmentation figured
out how you get somebody from a Chevy to
an Oldsmobile to a Buick to a Cadillac
and became a lifelong customer I mean he
brilliantly put together things and then
look what happened what's happened to
General Motors over the last 35 years it
is I don't know how it survives
seriously I mean it's it's clearly in
the bureaucracy aristocracy stage and if
you look at unfunded liabilities I mean
I think you have to you know if you're a
doctor you say this is this patient is
on the debt on its deathbed so there's
one all right well thank you very much I
wish y'all